people have been interested in
horse based on living rep
and unusually dark Browns or muted
greens in the late 90s people began to
discover feathered dinosaurs diners with
Dino fuzz
at that point became interesting to know
what that how that those feathers could
have influenced the appearance of it
we found out is that for
they preserve the melanin that is the
pigment to give the color to the feather
so the way that I got it
I got the idea that we could potentially
use this to put colors and dinosaurs
came from a very odd angle because I was
actually looking at fossils quits and we
find fossils quits that have the ink
sack preserved and quite interestingly
when you look at this fossilized ink you
can actually see that it preserves the
pigment and that made me think that we
should be able to find this pigment
which is melanin in other kinds of
fossils such as in for example feathers
melanin pigments are created
pigment cells which package them in
little organelles called melanosomes
these milena somes are tiny little
packages they come in oblong or rounded
shapes we have a locality in Denmark
that is about 55 million years old where
we find fossilized Birds with feathers
so when I took this fossil under a
scanning electron microscope and started
zooming in on the under fossil feathers
I was just met by this ocean of little
sausage shaped structures and that
confirmed my expectations that melon is
very abundant in fossils and also it
means that we can use this sort of
information to put colors on dinosaurs
what we were able to do was compare the
shape and size and density of the
Milano's ohms in these fossil feathers
to the feathers of living birds and
thereby interpret or predict the color
of these fossil feathers when the animal
was alive this has allowed us to create
the first description of the plumage
color of an extinct dinosaur in history
the dinosaur is an animal called ng onus
and it's about the size of a chicken and
it has a rather spectacular plumage
including red color on the crest and
spotting and bracketing of black and
white and gray colors on the rest of the
plumage what Rick he said when he first
saw this thing and we started realizing
what kind of color patterns it hath he
said it looks like a spangled Hamburg if
you see this NGO nurse as it's called
and just have a quick look at it and
look away I think most people would say
that it looks like a chicken
this fossil is from the latest Jurassic
of rounding Province in China so these
Chinese examples are extraordinary and
that many of them do have an outline of
the feathers on both extinct birds and
these are early dinosaurs and so the
interesting prospect of this is that we
can see that mountain is preserved in
all these fossil feathers it's the rule
rather than the exception
the future
paleontology and paleontology of birds
and and mammals will be that we we will
probably be able to reconstruct in some
detail the color that they had in life
this is like writing the first field
guide page in the field guide to the
dinosaurs and some of the most exciting
moments of science I've ever had